Hi there everyone. In this video, I am
throwing open the doors on a brand new
era of ESC testing at AOS Labs. I've
taken some time to develop a brand new
test methodology for ESCs that allows us
to look at the performance of these
pieces of hardware in unprecedented
detail.
In this video, I'm going to be taking
you through this new test methodology
and using it in anger on a bunch of ESCs
with BLHeli_32, AM32, and Blue Jay
firmware to see how they stack up. And
if that wasn't enough, then we're going
to be seeing how all of these ESCs
compare against something brand new from
FETtec. A prototype piece of hardware
and software for their new SFOC ESC.
This is simple field orientated control.
We're going to be talking about it a lot
at the end of this video, and it
promises to be a technological
revolution in FPV. Let's not waste any
more time. There's heaps to cover. Let's
dive right into it. All right, so let me
take you through the new test setup.
Starting with a prop, this hasn't
changed. This is still the HQ 5 by 4.5
by 3 V1S prop. And it's being driven by
the test motor, which is this AOS
Supernova 2207. The Supernova is the
highest performing 5-in motor available
in terms of power and torque, so it's
really going to put these ESCs through
their paces.
On the top of the test stand, we have
the ESC to be tested, and it's connected
to this flight controller on the side.
This is a normal F7 flight controller,
and this flight controller is doing
everything for this testing. It's
driving the ESC, and it's also recording
all of the data being reported back from
the ESC over bi-directional DShot. And
this setup allows much, much faster than
we could with the thrust test stand
alone. The test stand tops out at about
180 hertz, 180 samples per second. With
this flight controller, we can log at 8
kilohertz, 8,000 times per second.
This whole setup is powered from a 24-V
power supply that is topping up this
5,200 mA 6S pack. So, these ESCs are not
going to run out of power during the
testing.
We've got three tests. We've got a prop
ramp from 0 to 100% throttle and back
down again. We've got a prop
responsiveness test, so stepping from 10
to 50% throttle and back. And then we
also have a flywheel test using this 100
kg mm squared flywheel. And that's what
we need this massive capacitor for. It's
to deal with the current spikes
accelerating and decelerating this large
flywheel.
So, this is the new test setup. Now,
let's talk through the ESCs that we're
going to be looking at. All right. So,
these are the five ESCs we're going to
be testing today. We've got this 55 amp
8-bit ESC from SpeedyBee, and that's
running the BlueJay firmware 0.19.2.
We've got this Diatone Mamba F60 Pro
running AM32 version 1.99.
We've got the F55 amp Pro 3 from
T-Motor. That's running BLHeli32.10.
We have this Skystars KM55 amp 20 by 20
ESC, again running AM32 version 1.99.
And we have this brand new prototype ESC
from FETtec running their SFOC firmware
version 1.01.
Before we dive into the test results,
and they are really interesting, I want
to let you know about my open-door
testing policy. It's basically a free
testing service for FPV products. You
can send me motors, props, batteries,
and now ESCs, and I will test them for
you free of charge. I'll share the
results with you. I'll publish the
results on AOS Labs, and I'll make the
detailed test data available on my
Patreon. This free testing service is
available to everyone, and it's only
possible with your support. If you'd
like to support this testing and help me
expand my testing service further, then
please consider supporting me either
directly through Patreon or Buy Me a
Coffee, or indirectly using the
affiliate links you can find down in the
video description.
If you're thinking of buying some FPV
gear, or just making a purchase from
Amazon, please click through on my
affiliate link. It won't cost you
anything. Amazon will make a little bit
less profit off of you, and Jeff Bezos
will send a few bucks my way to help
continue this testing. It's a real
win-win, and I would really appreciate
any and all support that you can give
me. All right. So, the first test we're
going to look at is the throttle ramp.
Here, we are ramping the throttle on the
ESC from 0 to 100% over 5 seconds,
pausing at 100% throttle for half a
second, and then ramping back down to 0%
over 5 seconds. All right. Let's take a
look at the results of the throttle
ramp. On the X axis, we have time in
seconds, and on the Y axis, we have RPM
reported over bidirectional Dshot. And
the throttle setting at each point in
time is the same for all the ESCs.
What we can see is that all the ESCs
have pretty much identical RPM versus
throttle curves up to about 40%
throttle, and then they all start to
kink over slightly, and we get some
differences in shape at high throttle.
When we get to the peak RPM, so that's
full throttle, we can see that there's
about a 3% spread across all of these
ESCs, with an edge to the SpeedyBee ESC,
the BlueJay ESC, that achieves the
highest RPM, and the Mamba F60 Pro with
the AM32 firmware achieves the lowest
RPM at full throttle. This could be to
do with firmware, but can also be due
due to differences in the ESCs as well.
With the BlueJay SpeedyBee ESC, we see a
really interesting stepped response as
we get to very high throttle, and it's
quite apparent that it appears like
we're running out of throttle resolution
at the very top end, and that might lead
to the throttle being a little bit less
smooth, but that's probably not a big
deal because we don't spend a lot of
time at that high in the throttle.
It may also be due to the fact that this
is the only 8-bit ESC that I'm testing
today. All of the other ESCs are 32-bit,
and so they may just have more
resolution and have finer steps in
throttle. We see that the throttle
versus RPM curves are symmetric, they're
identical on the way up and on the way
down, which is good to see, and that um
they're pretty similar overall. So,
let's move on and look at the next test.
The next test we're going to look at is
the responsiveness of the ESC. And for
this test, we're going to be doing
throttle steps. We're stepping the ESC
from 10% to 50% throttle and then back
down to 10% again, and we're logging the
RPM as the ESC accelerates and
decelerates the motor. We're doing that
10 times, and then we're taking the
average of all 10 of those responses and
plotting them so we can look at how fast
the ESC is able to respond.
All right, so let's take a look at the
results of the ESC responsiveness test.
What you're looking at here is time on
the x-axis in milliseconds and RPM of
the motor on the y-axis.
All of the throttle steps start at
exactly 0 milliseconds, and you're
watching the ESC accelerate the motor
from about 6,000 RPM to 21,000 RPM as
fast as it possibly can.
We have a white dashed line that
indicates 90% of the RPM change on this
step. So, we're looking for the ESCs
that are the fastest to get to that 90%
line.
The slowest ESC is the T-Motor F55A
running BLHeli 32. You can see that it
takes about 52 milliseconds to reach
that 90% white line.
Then we have all of the AM32 and BlueJay
ESCs. They all take almost exactly the
same amount of time. It's 44
milliseconds to accelerate up to that
white 90% line. But the fastest ESC, by
some margin, is the new FETtec SFOC ESC.
That reaches 90% in just 40
milliseconds. And if we think of those
differences, you know, 52 milliseconds
versus 40 milliseconds, that's a 12
millisecond difference, and that's a
significant amount of delay. That's as
much delay as you're likely have on your
filters or your RC link. So, if you can
pick an ESC that is significantly faster
to accelerate the prop, that is going to
make the quad feel more responsive. And
I think pilots will be able to notice a
difference
with a difference of about 10
milliseconds in terms of how fast the
ESC accelerates the prop because we
definitely have anecdotal evidence that
there is a perceivable difference
between
um video links with 30 and 40
milliseconds of delay. So, I definitely
think that it's worth having this extra
responsiveness, and it's really
impressive to see this prototype FETtec
ESC um beating out all of the
established competition. When it comes
to deceleration, we can perform exactly
the same analysis. But in this case, we
find that all of the ESCs perform pretty
much exactly the same when decelerating
the motor, and there's no real
difference. We do see a little bit more
noise on the RPM signal at uh lower RPMs
for the FETtec SFOC ESC, but this is
prototype hardware, prototype software.
So, Felix is actively working on this,
and I expect that this will probably be
resolved long before the firmware is
actually released, and I will verify
that in future testing.
The final test we're going to look at is
the flywheel dyno test. And here, we're
accelerating the motor from 6 to 50%
throttle, and we have a 100 kg mm
squared flywheel attached to the motor.
The ESC that's able to accelerate the
motor more quickly with the flywheel
attached is able to generate more torque
out of the same motor, and therefore is
providing improved performance, and
that's what we're going to be looking at
with this test. This flywheel dyno test
is probably the most challenging test
for any ESC, and we can see a big
differences in performance between the
different ESCs that we're testing.
Again, we're looking at time on the
x-axis in milliseconds and rpm of the
motor on the y axis. And all of the
throttle steps are starting at 0
milliseconds, and then we're watching
the ESC try and accelerate that motor
with that flywheel attached as fast as
possible. We can see that the BLHeli_32
ESC, the T-Motor F55A, is the slowest to
accelerate that flywheel. That means
that it's generating the least torque.
Then we have the Skystars KM55A AM32
ESC. This is only a 20 by 20 ESC, so
it's a smaller ESC, and it's still able
to accelerate that flywheel nice and
quickly.
Then we have the SpeedyBee 55A BlueJay
ESC and the Mamba F60 Pro AM32 ESC.
These are 30 by 30 ESCs, and they are
generating a lot of torque, and they are
accelerating that flywheel really
quickly.
But again, the standout performer here
is this prototype FETtec 65A SFOC ESC.
It's able to generate significantly more
torque than all of the other motors and
accelerate that flywheel that much
faster.
I hope you found those test results
interesting. I am thrilled that we
finally have a tool that allows us to
see the differences between these ESCs
really, really clearly, and we can start
to understand which ESCs are performing
better and which are performing worse.
If you're interested to learn more about
the FETtec SFOC ESC and the totally new
and unique approach that they are using
to control the motor, then make sure
you're subscribed because I'm going to
be doing a video on that very, very
soon. We're going to be deep diving on
the technical detail behind their simple
field orientated control that they're
using to drive these motors.
That's all I have for you for today. So,
until next time, I wish you all very,
very happy flying, and I'll see you in
the next one.
Hey.